[Music]
right
here we are again family
it's been a trip so um
as you guys may or may not know well
if you can do maths you can guess we're
coming up to the one year anniversary
yeah [ __ ] come on your anniversary in a
couple weeks
yeah so if there's anything specific
that you guys want to
hear us talk about that would be dope um
[ __ ] september 29th yeah september well
yeah we started september 29th
um i don't know what day is
going to be the day we actually do the
i'll check that out yeah check the date
that
is going to be the anniversary so it
will be september 28th ironically
is it yeah september 28th one year
anniversary yeah
um it's going to be a trip so i'm
looking forward to it
so am i so yeah guys if there's anything
you want to hear us chat about
let us know um apart from that yeah man
the usual mission 1k moving shaking
shaking moving grooving
slooven um yeah man we're doing well so
guys again keep up with the michigan 1k
we might have a little
teasy sneaky something for you in a
couple months uh we're yeah we're
working in the process of yeah
now in a couple months for you guys so
yeah that's interesting hold tight yeah
keep pushing with the mission 1k and
thank you again as always
um always we're happy we're so happy
it's like it's been a trip um and
anyway yeah i don't want to get into the
i'll leave the reminiscent for the
one-year anniversary
yeah 100. um and again yeah merch always
flying we've got some new designs coming
your way in the next what month
couple months couple months new launch
in the next couple months
um should be dope and uh
urgent biz i don't have urgent business
but i feel like
i felt i felt like i've wanted to start
the pod in a different way
oh go on in terms of i didn't want to
tell you beforehand because i didn't
want it to be like a preemptive thing
for you too i like that yeah i like that
go on so
i want to just start off with like
random
facts not about us but just about random
[ __ ] in general
so i started writing some stuff down i
figured oh this is actually pretty
interesting
okay so i'll do i'll do probably one
every episode if i forget i forget if i
don't i don't
got it so you know the cut obviously you
know steaks
everyone everyone that eats meat loves a
steak yeah yeah yeah yeah
so do you know like do you know the myth
about it's a it's a myth
fact it's more of a myth anyway do you
know the myth of
the name sirloin the cut of the name
sirloin no no
so back in like the 1600s
there was like there was a king called
king james coincidence
um he was i think at a dinner in
edinburgh somewhere in scotland i think
something like that
and they served him a piece of loin
um obviously which is a cut of meat he
loved it so much he knighted it
and that's why it's called a sirloin he
sounds like a [ __ ] drunk
he sounds like a [ __ ] drunk speaking
of drunk
i think it was henry the eighth it was
one of the kings like back a day as well
this is another fun fact
google this but i'm not too sure how how
much truth this is but i've heard this
before
he like i think what's happening but
don't quote me it could have been king
already could be one of them [ __ ]
yeah
yeah
he loved titi so much he loved hot
cupping titties
that he designed the wine glass in that
form and that's why people have i've
heard that
hold white glasses i have heard that
yeah yeah i don't know if it it might be
henry viii actually yeah but i've heard
that yeah he loved
things he loved [ __ ] yeah he he had
wives
and he loved [ __ ] do you remember that
in brighton when you learned it i think
it was in secondary school you learned
it you said yeah
we're beheaded so what was the what was
that six yeah he had six wives
six wives i think it was like he
beheaded bear there he beheaded two of
them
it was like beheaded divorced died
beheaded divorce survived slightly like
yeah did you remember that
yeah did you vent divorce in i have no
idea
somewhere around that it wasn't a ting
that's why he was lopping heads
i have no idea i'm sure he was lopping
heads because divorcing wasn't a thing
imagine being his wife and the first
wife beheading
imagine me the second wife
[Laughter]
what's wrong with her why would you even
entertain the idea of being these hoes
love status that's what it is
these hoes love stagger so much they saw
a man kill off his first wife and
they're like i like my chances
the odds are in my favor now on a hunger
games man's a bachelor again
gang gang oh my days that's wild
that sirloin thing he was a drunk he was
sipping ale i can see that dinner as it
was red wine
red wine boy but i like that that's a
good concept yeah keep done coming
um we've got a fan request
[Music]
from molly moles um
so let me find it question
is there a oh god yeah is there a
difference between having sex with
someone who used to be a man
but now is medically changed to the
point where you couldn't tell so
they've had a sex change yeah surgical
sex change so
trans a woman trans woman yeah
everything's legit yeah is there a
difference between having sex with a
trans woman
post-op
and having sex with someone who used to
have a flat chest
stroke bum and then got surgery to
change it
assuming based on the assumption that
you wouldn't find them attractive
before the surgery so both obviously you
wouldn't find a man attractive yeah yeah
yeah and you wouldn't find in this
circumstance these
flat appendages um attractive
i think that's a hard question to ask
because i don't have experience in
[ __ ] a trans
woman so i can't really give context
because what is it is it what is there a
difference
yeah it's not necessarily a difference
in feel but is it like i think she's
talking more like a moral difference
um if you refuse to like okay she's
basically saying okay okay okay
[ __ ] a trans woman yeah which is okay
for you to
[ __ ] someone who's had a bbl if you
wouldn't have [ __ ] them without it
so you see a girl she's not [ __ ] hot
fam she's
dirt yeah but then she gets a bbl and
she's getting surgery and
titties and arse are fat yeah and you're
like your face is dirt but i will [ __ ]
just just based on body yeah knowing
that she you wouldn't affect her before
is that okay if you wouldn't have [ __ ]
the
the trans woman um that's actually a
really interesting question here's an
interesting question but i feel like
there's a there's a threshold within
what's okay and what's not okay spectrum
right there is a spectrum
so just because i wouldn't [ __ ] her when
she's flat chest in the flat arsen let's
say her face isn't that great
that's my that's a preference of mine do
you know what i mean
yeah and if i prefer thick girls and
she's made herself look thick
again that's my preference so yes i'm
gonna be more
attracted to it the same way if girls
like guys
with abs chest thick legs all of that
stuff
but then they wouldn't [ __ ] a fat guy
but if that guy toned the [ __ ] up they'd
[ __ ] him then
this is true but what she's saying is is
in the assumption
is that with the trans woman yeah you
only know
in this scenario i'm assuming that
basically she said the assumption is
the trans woman you find [ __ ]
attractive yeah so this is a woman that
you did not know was a man unless she's
[ __ ] said to me
she tells me i used to be a man okay um
i think i think if i didn't know i
and then she told me prior to [ __ ] i
don't think i'd [ __ ] her
and that's well of course that's
i don't think i need a justification
just i don't think i need to justify
myself and as to why
this is the thing right i'll say my
piece after as well yeah but
this thing is gonna [ __ ] annoy the
[ __ ] yeah the stands are not
we're yeah we're going back to the arms
we'll go back to the arms after this
i'll continue um with this [ __ ] [ __ ]
i don't think you should be afraid to
say
if it's morally
how do i explain it if you don't know
what you're going to do you don't have
to justify it
regardless if someone says it's immoral
or whatever yeah you still
if that's how you feel that's how you
it's just how you feel yeah and that
goes on to what we've been writing about
all day
yeah but certain things are like yeah
just in terms of this like
the if you want to call it uh i don't
know like a council culture or social
injustice or
whatever you want to call it or equal
opportunities uh equality everywhere
yeah
as unfortunate as it is you feel how you
feel yeah
and if you feel like a trans woman
telling you
i used to be a man will be a turn-off
for you yeah
i don't think you should have to think
of a justification yeah as to why
yeah if in the same context in a
parallel
situation where someone who else was
surgically modified but has always been
a woman
you would still [ __ ] them i don't think
you should feel the need to have to
justify yourself
but i found it interesting that in the
world that we live in you knew
that you had to announce that you don't
want to have to justify yeah do you know
what i mean yeah you couldn't just say
no no i wouldn't and that's the end of
it because you the world we live in
nowadays today
you have to have a reason why so you
don't have to i don't have this is my
preference it's just your preference
i don't have to i don't i don't if i
could have to but here we are
justifying ourselves this did you think
that's an interesting thing it was very
that's why i was more interested about
you continuing to talk
yeah because i knew what your answer was
i knew before i even [ __ ] you up
but it's the fact that to watch you
think of a justification it's a
justification
when really you're pro you're pretty
much plucking out a thin air yeah
because you don't have a justification
you don't need a justification like
you've got this just how you feel in it
yeah sometimes i feel like we live in a
world where you
it's not okay to just chalk it up to
that's just how i feel
yeah my face yeah this is your truth and
like
you don't have to like if someone says
why you just i don't know why i just
isn't it like the more you try to
justify it
the deeper the grave you're digging
because you're not it's not
i feel like a lot of time when people
ask for justifications
you're bound to just dig yourself into a
deeper hole yeah or a lot of the time
when people do dig themselves a hole you
know when people say oh mate you just
dig in now yeah
the main reason is because they're
looking for justifications that they
don't have
yeah they just know they feel a certain
way yeah it's like someone saying to me
why aren't you gay
i don't know why i'm not gay yeah like
i'm just not yeah and like justify to me
why you're not gay like what's wrong
with men like what is this like you are
a man how can you not be gay
you don't mind touching your own dick
why would you not touch another man and
it's just like
the more i try and justify the way i
feel yeah the more of a [ __ ] i end up
sounding because it's not my true
justification
it's just is yeah it just is and
sometimes that just needs to be enough
for people
molly i'm not saying that you're
demanding justification i'm just saying
in this circumstance
it's interesting like it's just i don't
know why i don't know why
because i'm i'm with you just so to get
my point across sorry
i'm with you if um i found a trans woman
extremely attractive
and i found out that she used to have a
penis
and she used to go by dave and now she's
a woman
called eva and i think eva's sexy but
she says i used to be dave
all of this is funny how eva is just
dave backwards without the d i didn't
even realize that
um yeah like these times
if she's like oh are you still down yeah
i feel like
i'm sorry maybe it might be different in
this situation what
[Music]
i don't realize what i just said until i
said it and it's a [ __ ] punchline
it's a [ __ ] punch line you said
without the d i just got
i just i just i just got it i just got
it i just got it
it's just dave backwards without the d
she's got oh my days you man you're
welcome yeah yeah yeah yeah you're
welcome
let me take a sip i deserve a break
[Laughter]
that's funny wow you actually nailed
that i mean you're welcome because i
said that even though
i don't know um whatever but yeah um
yeah if he rolls to me and said yeah i
used to be dave
i had my adam's apple shaved off i had
my dick cut in half turned inside out
and shoved inside me my [ __ ] feels real
um but we can do angular if you'd like
like whatever titties i got them now
all this stuff and i'm looking at i
think she's buff as soon as she says i
used to be dave
granted i've never been in that
situation yeah so i don't know for a
fact yeah that my boner's gonna go i
don't know that
yeah yeah yeah yeah just fairly certain
it is yeah you think that it will
yeah because you know yourself i know my
body i know i don't know i know how i
feel about something yeah so yeah
granted i might be wrong she might do it
and i'll be like i don't give a [ __ ]
like suck me off i don't care like your
bath i might be like your bath
let's go but my body and my brain and my
heart tells me
unto my heart my soul tells me that i'm
gonna blame eva i'm sorry guys i'm just
not about it anymore
yeah not your fault i'm just not about
anything yeah but i don't need a
justification for it it's just how i
feel because there are people there will
be people out there that
are okay with that and that should be
okay for them that should be not
necessarily should be enough
because i feel like
me being because i if that question if
that proposition got put towards me
i feel like me saying no
is enough for them to
not be offended because it's not like
i've abused them i've taken the piss out
of them or anything like that
it's my preference well yeah it doesn't
make you transphobic exactly what you're
trying to make guys that's the thing as
well exactly
and especially if they know you as a
person oh especially that
because i've had like i i said this
earlier when i was talking about favors
mm-hmm we were talking about perfumes
and someone kept asking me for favors
yeah yeah yeah and i've
like i've had like a person in my life
that asks for favors and i grant a lot
of favors
yeah so when i grant a lot of favors you
shouldn't i shouldn't have to explain
myself
the 19th time when you ask for a certain
favor and i say no
i shouldn't have to justify to you why
i'm saying no because i do enough for
you
you know you have enough of a catalogue
to be like james isn't a [ __ ]
yeah like if he's saying you know then
it's a night and that should be the same
view like
food is not a bad guy so if he's saying
no
i shouldn't take offense because he's
not a transphobic person he's not a [ __ ]
like he's he's a cool guy and if he's
not about it then he's just not about it
yeah
um but yeah that's an interesting
question uh to answer so what is the
answer is there a difference
i guess morally in black and white
no in my opinion there's no difference
between
someone surgically becoming an attract
from a man who i'm not attracted to
to a woman i am attracted to as opposed
to someone having a body i'm not
attracted to
to surgically becoming a body i am
attracted to morally speaking
there is no difference yeah and if it
was a black and white
robotic world yes i would [ __ ] both of
them
yeah equally post surgery yeah but
we're human beings we are human beings
we are fickle we don't have explanations
for everything that we feel we're
entitled to feel how we feel we're
entitled to feel how we feel and if i
say
sorry cause it's a no from me a no no
that's enough that's that's gonna happen
that should be enough
bro we're gonna keep it running but
actually i'm bursting for a piss out of
nowhere
so you can chat you can i can edit it
out i don't care all right bro let me
piss
have you seen this bella thornton i've
see
i've seen people talk about it but i've
not seen
like i kind of i don't know it's about
yeah yeah the the
only fantastic fans yeah the new thing
that wasn't a nude she made a million
pounds off it a million dollars of it
and she's now
[ __ ] up only fans for everyone else in
terms of like
the capping of the money and the i
didn't know about capping money they've
capped tip in
they've you can't withdraw whenever you
want you can only withdraw once a month
now stuff like that
is [ __ ] up so much i don't i don't
have the answers i don't really care
um but interesting yeah so for context
if anyone's not aware
bella thorne so she used to be
people pissing this cup off a banner in
it oh yeah right oh snap i care i don't
feel so bad now
context yeah so um she is what does she
do now is she an actress i have no idea
bro say she used to be on disney channel
internet back in day
oh she used to be in disney when she was
a kid or whatever
and she decided to come out and say i'm
going to do only fans
and in in 24 hours she hit a million
quid
a million dollars a month in 24 hours
that's disgraceful and then in the first
week she made up to 2 million
so now she's earning 2 million a month
from oni fans
but she never said i'm doing nudes yeah
she just said i'm doing only fans so
people have gone on there
and there's no nudes but what i've seen
on twitter is
she said because when i think when they
when she posted a pic or whatever
obviously it's blurred or like you can't
see the pick and i think like in the
caption was
lane this is what i'm i'm giving you
what i saw from what the ladies video
was
okay she said oh laying here naked in
bed or something like that
so you have to pay to pray it obviously
yeah yeah apparently it was like 200
to pre it and i think first of all let's
pause the video here
yeah who's paying 200
bellathon i just googled her she's not
even that bad average she's
does she's not curvaceous and it's like
but everyone's taste is different don't
get me wrong so it is what it is
but anyway 200 for a picture man just
google her
do you know what i mean bro just google
her um so apparently she wasn't she
wasn't naked
but obviously you don't know that until
you pay for it and then
she racked up a mill and then it caused
controversy but
do you say controversy what do you think
controversy controversy controversy
anyway
um it caused it calls that and then she
it caused a lot of people to ask for
refunds
off omni fans so that's what that's what
started [ __ ] up some stuff
logistically and then it then put a cap
on how much you can tip people
that and then [ __ ] it up for only fans
for everyone because people started
asking for
it then put a cap on how much money how
many times you can request to
take your money out of the only fans
account and put it into your main
account apparently you can only do it
once a month now as opposed to doing it
whenever you wanted to well that's how
it is for patreon i know you can't
withdraw patreon
i think it's like two days in a row or
there's there's a certain amount of time
we can't yeah we can't just withdraw
from patreon all the time yeah and
that's probably why
because you can just throw something up
there yeah and just like sign up for
this amount
yeah this amount and um we're going to
give you this and then we wait for
everyone to sign up and they're like
not really and then just take the money
um because yeah once we've got it we've
got it
yeah there's no refunds um
but boy yeah i didn't know about that
she i didn't know she lied about the
thing yeah
but regardless who's paying 200 that's
what i'm saying like pause the video
there man then
you're to see you're naked in bed you're
the idiot
pornhub is free you're the idiot for
paying two bills
don't deserve a refund you don't you
don't deserve a refund
[ __ ] hell and like it doesn't matter
who it is
bellathon like like i said i don't even
think she's attractive anyway but
i think it was because of the celebrity
status of it or who she is
or whatever of course it's that but
again you could have just watched porn
that day and be 200 pound
up or 200 yeah did she not think like
it would bite her and ask no not that i
buy an ass but like when she thought oh
i'm not
obviously i'll post this for clickbait
yeah yeah and then once she's racked up
two mil
would you not think maybe i should just
start releasing nudes
maybe i should do the news two meal fam
two mil a month
i saw someone post on twitter today
funny and i thought you said day or
yesterday
someone tweeted what are the girls doing
that aren't doing only fans
and someone quote tweeted trying to find
a way to do only fancy with confidence
i just like fair enough if you're buff
and you're fair enough
do only fans only fans makes you
okay remember the yeah that
i don't know if you saw you you must
have seen the video it came out like two
weeks ago and it just went viral
the chick that um sucked off the
basketball players
champion champion first of all let's
i'll talk about early fans then we'll go
back to her yeah
yeah so sorry
i saw i saw an only fan she made like
63 grand in a day or something like this
yeah
only fans yeah she's got no defense okay
because when i when i saw
when i saw it on like twitter and stuff
i went to watch the actual
thing on youtube the actual interview on
youtube but the chick that did
the jobs the [ __ ] wasn't tagged it
was a bridge that was tagged
she's a weirdo that bridgette the
bredrin just loves money she loves money
in life she's yeah
she has no moral she doesn't care she
reminds me of like harley quinn like a
real harley quinn
she's a great yeah yeah [ __ ] creep
but she that's her life
yeah obviously yeah anyway yeah do we
i almost envy that yeah i almost said
with that because you got she's got
genuine freedom i almost sent me that
for context um
so i went on this this initial girl's
instagram to find this girl's other
instagram that was doing all the suck
jobs and whatever sock drops that's from
memphis for family
yeah yeah suck jobs suck jobs contacts
suck jobs if you've not seen ever family
on netflix
funniest thing it's an eye contact suck
jobs
funniest thing she knows um and then
yeah i was scrolling through a thing and
i think i saw it the day after
she just she showed her other girl on
instagram story she made like 63 or 64k
one day
and i'm thinking wow and obviously prior
to this interview
she wasn't she i don't think she had
only fans or if she did it wasn't
obviously raking the amount she's making
she's obviously now a lot more famous
because of this thing which is
understandable like you need that clout
you need that initial push yeah for the
moment
yeah and now she's got the momentum a
lot of people know about a lot of people
want to [ __ ] her
and they're gonna have to pay to [ __ ]
her do you know what i mean and if she
if she's about this whole life and about
just not necessarily her life
like if that's the life she chooses to
live she's about don't even know i don't
know she's like i know i know but like
she's she's not a porn star
she's just living her life and making
money and it's like
i don't condone or not non-condone it
like it doesn't really affect me in any
form
any slight or whatever i don't really
care but it's just the fact that she's
owning it
oh which i've said a million times for
him if you say something with chess
chess i rate you i don't care what it is
you said as long as you say it with
chest
it's fine it doesn't matter she's
[ __ ] owning it but anyway
sorry to cut you off back to the sucking
seven man off
in the room rotation first of all
have you seen the full interview no i've
seen i've only seen the part pretty much
i think this is one that you put in
was it either bit in the group i think
so i've only seen the one in the group
chat where she said
she was getting [ __ ] by one guy that
works with the team then seven man came
in
and then she sucked all seven men off
and she they she
swallowed all of their nuts i the first
thing not to fear to be fair the first
thing i i
the first thing i didn't think about is
what i'm going to say the first thing i
was thought about was thinking ra
that's just the first thing like i
didn't know things like that existed
me neither do you know what i mean me
neither like i knew there was a realm of
status where [ __ ] just happens to you
because you're famous you're wealthy
you're good
looking blah blah blah but i just didn't
think i didn't think
things like that existed i didn't think
that there were yets that are out there
in this
in this world that would just be happy
to do that for you because of who you
are
because who you are that just it blew
my mind like in their head in her head
she's just like i'm about to suck off an
entire basketball team
that's the starting five and two benches
she's bench warmers
not to talk off the breath she's already
bitten she's like he's already been
[ __ ]
so it's not even like she's just horny
as [ __ ] she was getting collapsed from
the back
her cheeks were getting smacked up
already already he's probably already
sucked him off
and then seven man rolled in the room
and said cool
and it's what's going on in here and
because she knew it was going to happen
and people have people especially saying
it was the phoenix suns but i don't
really care i don't really know i don't
give a [ __ ] what possible team was um
but imagine i wouldn't mind going first
the seventh guy this is the way i
thought about it right so how would i
think about this
because she swallowed six nuts i'm not
lips in her
so obviously obviously not so i'm saying
what would deter me what i'm trying to
think
if i was deterred again i'm looking for
justification there might not be one
if i'm deterred what exactly is it
that's deterring me
maybe putting yeah maybe putting my dick
in if i might have to just give her a
glug of water
after if i'm number seven yeah my number
six donny
come like is finished i might just give
her like a quick water
and just it's just goggling spit
so i know i'm at least putting my dick
in a mouth that isn't filled with [ __ ]
yeah then maybe but
seven you'll be if you're number seven
you're waiting for a long time
because nothing from heads it takes me a
minute
it takes me a minute so there must have
been a bit of penetration here and there
just to like
quick up the process do you know what i
mean no she said she didn't [ __ ] any of
them i know
but that's what she she could be
challenging we don't know
i mean she had to be fair she probably
that seems like a weird detail to me
about yeah do you know what i mean if
you're willing to say i sucked off the
entire team
why would you say but i only [ __ ] want
this one guy
if you actually [ __ ] other guys i'm not
waiting there if i'm number seven
i'm not i don't think i'll be put off
but i'm not waiting i think
the way if i was in that basketball
group i think
how i'd have to do it mentally or be in
that mental state to actually let her do
it to me is if
i weigh outside and not even see the
first six
because i couldn't be in that room in
like first of all what hotel room are
you in
to enable six seven man convin times
this is during corona this is during the
night what was before currently was it
before corona because i wasn't seeing
the bob or whatever that bubble taking
it wasn't drawing bubble
he wasn't sure i'm positive because they
can't you can't get in and out
the bubble's locked down okay no hoes
are coming in and out okay
trust me they've tried they've tried no
hoes are coming in okay
okay and i'm sure they're trying to
patent something okay but it's it's
locked down that's what's on this
because disney world uh if you've never
been disney was like on an island
so you can't just walk in and out
you have to get on a boat to get there
oh i've never fought there's no game oh
right we went
with my family a few years ago it's no
game okay so yeah this bubble thing
oh is that where the bobble thing was
yeah they were in disney world oh okay
um i don't know so they're in disney
world that's where the nba is right now
and that's where the bubble is and stuff
so they're not in you you can't secure a
home in
you can't okay and maybe they did which
is why all of them felt the need to get
sucked off
by one thing because this is all they
had maybe
she was filth as well she looked filth
as well she looked she looked like she'd
do the job
ah that's probably why i was quick to
get 47. i bet she sucks a fantastic
penis
but i was thinking as well the only way
i could confidently be
number seven yeah is if i'm the star
player
and i could just applaud oh my this is a
favor i'm doing to you
man uh we all know i can be number one
if i want if i wanted to do if i don't
know
if i want you yeah i can tell donnie get
out yeah if i'm lebron james yeah
i can be who whatever number i wanted
yeah like ice is my team
this is my thing and she'll suck me off
with pleasure she'll
gladly do it do you know her life goal
is to [ __ ] drake she said it
she's got a great tattoo isn't it right
she's got the she's got the
ovo owl and she's got saturn else that's
like drake symbolic
she said her life i'm drake i'm [ __ ]
happy so the life goal is to [ __ ] drake
i was like how is that and that's just
because he's a guy that's got status we
said this wasn't the first thing we
spoke about
he's so weird it's so weird
that like maybe this is just me drake
knows drake knows for a fact that there
are hoes that would die to [ __ ] him
but it must be a small kind of
outfitting in his head
yeah that this girl sucked off let's
call it the phoenix hands
she sucked off the entire starting
lineup of the phoenix suns
yeah and she did it gladly and she was
happy to do it
but she's still willing to come out
that's probably
in terms of [ __ ] people or whatever
that's her accolade this is her highest
accolade
i [ __ ] off the entire phoenix suns
team
gang but
my dream is to [ __ ] drake
if i'm drake chilling in my living room
watching that
i'm like i'm the sickest guy on planet
earth 100
i'm as far as chicks wanting to [ __ ]
chicks want to [ __ ] me than the entire
phoenix suns
and drake loves basketball yeah he must
be thinking i'm the guy
look at my mansion i'm the guy
i'm the guy i feel like with drake i was
talking about this
i would have to [ __ ] her if i
i honestly think actually before we get
on to drake
did you hear because you didn't watch
the whole you didn't see the whole
interview with this chick
you've probably not heard this but she's
[ __ ] trey songz
i did hear that did you hear this bit no
i didn't i've heard about it i've heard
other people
like i've listened to other podcasts and
stuff they're actually talking about it
yeah so i've heard that she said
trader pissed on her [ __ ] yeah so
initially like
they [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] and apparently
he he goes for rounds apparently so she
said she was knackered anyway
that doesn't surprise doesn't surprise
[Laughter]
so apparently he it's like a
um a casino type ambiance he doesn't let
them see the time
concept like he said if you
go as crazy at it the fact that they get
so much [ __ ] that they've got
their games they've got like this is it
like this is not even like
a woman i hope she tries i hope she lets
me [ __ ] or whatever it's like
when she comes around this is what i've
got planned for today
let you know what i mean like this is my
game because pussy's not [ __ ] to them
anymore yeah like it's not an equal
ground like me [ __ ] a girl right now
is equal footage yeah yeah yeah i want
to [ __ ] her she wants to [ __ ] me like
let's get into it with them it's like i
know she i know she needs to [ __ ] me
because i'm trey
yeah so i need i can pat on this thing
just to make it more exciting for me
yeah because she's boring to me because
she's yeah she's paying but
but she's just anything like every pen
girl i can [ __ ] anyone i choose yeah so
i just go through my idea i'm just like
anyone i choose the casino the casino of
jesus
this is his realm today so he said
apparent she said apparently he dangled
her phone out of their balcony and say
if you try and leave whatever i'm gonna
drop your phone
something like that i'll say drop it i'm
leaving as soon as soon as he says that
drop it i'm leaving i don't know what
you've got planned i don't know what
you've got
what do you mean science don't make
threats
don't make physical threats i'm leaving
sight is stupid yeah yeah and then she
was like
i think they [ __ ] again and he said to
her get in the shower
was like okay and then he's like i'll
play with your teeth she's like okay
he's like i'll play with your [ __ ] he's
like okay and apparently he was like
jacking off whatever and he just pissed
on her and just like all right
i was just like see
the pissing thing i would never i don't
feel like i would ever piss on a girl
it's not for me pissing with the hard-on
is impossible
it's the worst thing it is horrible it's
the worst it's horrible so first of all
i don't want to piss what i'm jacking
off
secondly ask for consent that if there's
anything
about consent it's just like don't just
piss on someone the brethren said she'll
let
someone [ __ ] on her chest for 10 grand
wow
i'd probably let someone sell my chest
for 10 grand shit's not sit yeah [ __ ] i
said sorry i meant to say [ __ ] you let
someone shut your chest for 10
probably 10 grand [ __ ] though
on my chest it's not in my mouth i know
my chest and once it's done i'm just
like
i'll just roll to the side and let it
lock off and then i just need to clean
up 10k
for a bit of [ __ ] rags rags it's not
rags
i don't think i don't think it's rags
for those that don't understand what
rags means
it means like of course of course hands
down without a shadow of a doubt no
brainer
yeah yeah but i don't think it's rags
i think because you're thinking so
exclusively about the 10 grand you don't
care about what the
the the task you have to do is yeah do
you know what i mean
yeah i don't know where you're going
with this yeah i don't have to deal with
the lie down
and let someone squat over me yeah [ __ ]
on my chest
nah i won't like it i'll hate it
i want to kill the person i want to kill
them
but 10 bags on camera
on i don't care i don't care
i don't know i'm camera for who i don't
know if um because obviously i'm not
ruining my reputation yeah i'm not gonna
abuse my livelihood for 10 grand
but [ __ ] in private [ __ ] on chess 10k
run me my p
fam hurry up
obviously it also depends on the type of
[ __ ] because if you're
spraying [ __ ] on me running [ __ ]
diarrhea [ __ ] i'm not i'm not doing
diary shift 10k
maybe like 50. if it's like a solid
healthy fibrous if you've been eating
bare album
and you just it's a wholesome
dollop yeah dollop and it's just like
it's got some weight to it
and you just [ __ ] off i'll take my
tanker i'll i'll let you i will
i'll firm it take my 10k oh firmament
take my tank diarrhea 50.
yeah diary 50. that will splatter fat
i'll be
so angry they'll splash stink
you'll [ __ ] stink i think i don't
think i'll be able to look at her the
same
like again i don't of course not but i'm
just doing it for 10k
i know um that's funny back to the only
fans bit
this is actually similar to the chest
thing if you were in bellathorne's
position
yes so youfu had so is sa only fans
contacted you tomorrow yeah
and said two mil a month guaranteed
yeah two million guaranteed only fans
yeah
and you it's request hour so you
like you have to do no penetration okay
but you have to do wherever
the fans want okay so positions okay
lingerie everything i have to wear
lingerie face down like naked face down
ass up
everything two million a month that's
the only people that are seeing it are
the people that pay
and there's no form of like screen shot
in them there's no screenshot nothing
you can't screenshot in nothing they pay
for their only fans
it's not advertised so only people who
are about their own fans life you don't
have to put it on your own instagram or
anything like that
only people that are about this uh like
only fans life they know that you're the
hot topic
my i feel like my pride and my
masculinity will take over i know it's
too big
i know i know i don't know let me finish
before you get excited
go i'm sorry sorry sorry i thought
you're backing out go on
i'm thinking about it all right go on
i'm allowed to think sorry i didn't know
i thought you were giving me your final
statement the brief
cuz all right go and go [ __ ] no jump
into conclusions like a [ __ ] yeah
anyway i it
my initial thought as soon as you said
it two millimeters i was thinking this
is going to go west because
as soon as you offer me so much money i
already know it's going to go left yeah
you have to already
ever i know it's good when you said
lingerie fam lingerie
i don't i don't even know how that will
feel on me it doesn't matter how we're
feeling you fat because it's too bad
rough it could be smooth you don't have
to do it and said face down arse i
didn't like my ass being touched bam
face down
arse up and you have to like not even
hands here yeah
hands on how you fold it back so you
look back and your face is against the
thing
and your back that is spread
you have to do all sorts ah but you only
have to record like
two or three days a month oh they're not
even pictures they're videos
from whatever the fans want if they want
pics if they want vids
if they want you to peel a banana with
your toes like wherever you want fam
it's just nothing has nothing will ever
have to go inside you so you never have
to suck anything yeah
you never have to put anything up your
ass i'll do it for the first month and
quit
now they that's what i was gonna say as
well i forgot that but you have to
you have to they've got you on retainer
for at least a year
oh so they popped it's two million a
month but they promise you
it's a 24 mil contract
i'll do it for 12 months yeah calm
i'll do it calm so would i i wouldn't
even think about it
you would think about it i'd [ __ ]
myself a team in a month you'd
think about it i'm not saying you
wouldn't do it you think i think about i
wouldn't contemplate it though because i
know i'm doing it no matter what
i've known as soon as they said no
nothing penetrative you just do
as soon as they say nothing's going
inside my body yeah sign me the [ __ ] up
where do you want my signature cuz i'll
sign him with blood
[Laughter]
i started with blood where do you want
it that's funny
fam i'm not down for it that's funny
but yeah man no before we go to duty i'm
at the assaulting
i said i want to get back to drake oh of
course yeah go on
obviously we both agree drake is great
artist of all time in my opinion anyway
i think he's he's just well okay you're
very speculative
no no i i feel like he's the greatest
artist alive i'm just trying to think of
i think is the greatest i've
ever okay alive that's what i mean right
now like he's you can't really top him
yeah
yeah so when i see that he does
features with some people i sometimes
think to myself
does he have like a little chat with his
voice and like who should i pick next
probably you know what i mean like i
love the song he's got with lil dirk now
but i've never listened to a little dark
song in my life and i probably never
will jokes out they're doing
favors that's what i'm saying he's doing
something i feel like he's just doing
favors because he can
and every i don't know if you've noticed
but every song or almost every song is
featured on in like the last
two two and a half years he raps first
and i think that's
that creates
that how do i even explain it that just
proves the kind of level he's on
yeah yeah yeah no a feature is never
goes first true
never goes first true never goes first
true he goes first for the last like two
and a half years apart from probably
i think there's a track he's got with
pie next door i can't remember what's
called that and probably one other one i
can't think of right now
he goes first i didn't think about it
goes first
that's wild and it's just like i know
every song he drops is a banger and i
always i always think
like he's got he's just got he's got
bangers on bangers bangers on his phone
and he just started flicks it
and then pixels like you man have this
one for today like the same time when
like when you want to pick somewhere to
go and you're rich you just
spin a globe and you stop it and like
we'll go there i feel like that's what
drake does
because he's bored like he's got two
everything he does
everything he touches turns to gold
turns to gold
everything he touches turns to god
that's wild i don't i don't feel like
anyone can argue with that statement yes
there are great rappers out there
and there'll probably be a lot of
speculative chat about this because like
there's no one saying he's the best
rapper alive he's just the
the greatest artist alive he is he's
just contradictory
but rapper i'm not supposed to be a
rapper like it's not necessarily about
his rapping yeah it's not necessarily
about the production
it's not it's it's all-encompassing yeah
yeah yeah all of it together yeah he is
the greatest he's the greatest
no one can touch him and the funny thing
about him is that obviously
a lot of people have only listened to
what he does like
in the last three four five years maybe
but then when you listen to like old
playlists and old songs from like 10 and
11 years ago
you actually appreciate the boss he was
saying then as well like when i listened
to
not thank me later um what's the one
with the black and white one i can't
remember
his first mixtape his first mix first
first first big tape jesus christ
um with um [ __ ]
[ __ ] best they ever had and all that
that i had that in my head when you were
just saying that mixtape
not that song specifically but that
makes they have a camera but it's called
um there are songs on there where his
bars are just like
[ __ ] but you didn't appreciate that same
because you were just learning about
dracula
you didn't really beat that yet but when
you listen to when you listen back now
i think wow yeah bro he's he's got bars
for days for days
he's like bro and some of the songs like
they don't hit you not even just that's
the thing you're talking about lyrics
like not even just lyrics but just like
the song as a whole
of the song they hate you i was
listening what did i message you the
other day and said this album
actually [ __ ] bangs uh the one with
uh
tuscan leather on it that's my favorite
album what's it called nothing was the
same yeah
that's my favorite that's my favorite
jacob nothing was the same it's a
[ __ ]
album that's the best album he's ever
done in my opinion a lot of people say
it's um
take is it take care the one before yeah
thank you nothing was the same as hands
down
bro nothing was the same it has such
bangers on it it's unbelievable it's
crazy it's unbelievable and i haven't
listened to it in years
there was a time i was listening to it
almost every day you know when i was
used to work
later at work really almost every day
two and throw two and three almost every
day
it's an amazing album it is an amazing
it's an amazing yeah jake's the guy man
i'm not surprised that girl will give
anything to [ __ ] him
i would have to [ __ ] that girl i don't
think anyone's really understand
no one else is here but you don't get
how much i'd have to fight the girl if i
was drake the
the ego that she's throwing at me
and she doesn't even know me you're a
professional thought
a professional thought and your dream
your dream [ __ ]
you're you're literally a fame [ __ ]
yeah and your highest accolade as a fame
[ __ ] is to [ __ ] me
to the point where you've got my [ __ ]
tattooed on your skin
and we've never even met we've never
spoke nothing
and you're you're you're desperate to
[ __ ] me and you [ __ ] celebrities for
banter for p she'll [ __ ] him for free
i'd have to [ __ ] her
not even he's got a song called for free
that's so funny yeah
yeah yeah she does not even yeah not
even because i think she's banging or
not even
yeah yeah yeah just for her yeah just to
do that
just to see how grateful she is that she
got to [ __ ] she would do
anything in bed for him anything and
everything
anything in bed
well that's a lot to take in it is what
i mean anything anything
and you know when we spoke about
you know we spoke about like back in the
day you spoke about
like girls who don't like so we use it
like how people like to say some girls
don't like giving head
yeah and we'll say the girls who say
they don't like giving her just haven't
met the man that they do they'd love to
suffer yes yes
yes that's you do suck it up
yes for drake yeah she would do anything
i don't know if i've said this on here
but i probably have i'm going to repeat
it again
i know someone i'm obviously not going
to say names but i know someone
that has a friend that said she will
never suck dick like ever
look i think she's done it before she
didn't really like it and then she just
didn't do it anymore yeah
blah blah she was always adamant about
it i was like
i don't i just don't believe that and it
but it is what is i don't really care
but then she's now seeing someone and
she told the the uh the middleman that
our mutual that
she s sucked him off and i was like
fancy
i was like gang she fancies
she looks at him and thinks [ __ ] i want
to please you fam
yes ah and that's that's the that's the
art of giving head like you don't do it
for
i don't think i don't give girls head
well if i want to give them head anyway
i don't give them head for them not
different from me
fam like if you see a [ __ ] sexy woman
i think i want to sit on my face
all i want to do is eat you out that's
all i want to do and i don't want to do
it for me
i don't look at there's girls that like
there's girls obviously that i've slept
with in my life yeah
that i'm not i'm not eating you out i'm
just
i'm just not gonna do it i have no
interest
for what reason it happens nah
it happened but yeah when you fancy
fancy someone yeah you'd like
i would do anything to eat you up yeah
it's crazy it's crazy like went up like
when i've eaten the first time i ate ass
yeah
i in that moment i would have done
anything
do you know what i mean anything she
should she could have shoved her foot in
my mouth
and i would have been like do you know
what i mean i know exactly when you're
in the moment
nothing else matters bubble in that
moment
nothing else it was all attraction
bro it was i know exactly what you mean
though it's magic
all right let's let's let's do all right
we're gonna we're gonna go rubble on the
kid [ __ ]
rabbit hole all right cool uh
oh this is the same old song so for this
one
am i the [ __ ] for forcing my vegan
daughter to cook meat
god right
they fall on here fam people hate vegans
on reddit
um i might yeah i might have ourselves a
force in my vegan daughter to cook me so
my daughter six can i answer before you
say the context and then let's see if i
change my mind at the end
yeah i think that's a good one yeah i
feel like from that status from that
uh statement alone or that header alone
am i the answer for making my vegan
daughter cook meat
i think yes i think yeah morally 100 yes
yeah yeah morally but let me give you
context first of all i hope i changed my
mind
that's sad because i always i always
know them before
yeah yeah but that's fine
it's great for me though it's great for
them as well so great
um my daughter 16 been vegan for about a
year
uh my husband me my husband and her
little brothers 14 have tried to be as
supportive as
possible so um
we're not a family who eats meat daily
so it wasn't that hard to accommodate
her
when i do cook me i also make something
else for her
um she does have some separate dishes
but most are common
uh and i clean it if i have to cook for
her cool yeah
so a few months since she tried to
convince us to all go vegan
and she'd get more and more angry when
we said no
me and my husband shut that behavior
down hard and told her that she can
follow whatever she wants but you can't
expect others et cetera et cetera et
cetera
raiden's uh yeah so last weekend i
cooked the family a big pot of chili
a small vegan one and a large beef one
so that i can refrigerate and use it for
next week
next day i found the fridge empty of
both chilies and turns out my daughter
decided that
we are being too callous about me she
felt the smell was too much when she
opened the fridge door
and that she can't and that she can't
have i'll she misspelled can't have
anything from the fridge
um after that without gagging or puking
okay she told me that i need to throw
all the vegan food in the fridge and
restock it
the mum said that to the door no the
daughter so basically oh yeah again
so me and my husband were livid wasting
food is never okay with us
and that was a lot of food um i told her
i'm gonna continue to use the vegan
products in the fridge and she can
either eat it or not but i'm not wasting
the food
um as punishment i gave her the risk the
recipe
and told her she needs to buy them and
cook it next weekend
she yelled and begged but i stood firm
in the end she did it
when the cooking was finished i told her
that wasn't food is never okay
being used too
but how awful so yeah now she started
crying about how awful and disgusting
i was because i not only forced her to
buy me uh i was supposed to cook it
um am i wondering am i the [ __ ] and
did i take it too far
i'm gonna point up i'm gonna bring up
the point about
her saying when she opened the fridge
and smell
the meat smell and i made a gag i can
empathize with that in a sense of
i'm intolerant to crustaceans as a
mollusk which you know yeah so like
anyone that doesn't know what this
that's like shellfish
oysters and all that kind of things but
when i say that to people
people say to me oh you're missing out
that's their first thought yeah
especially people that love that kind of
dish yeah but they don't know what i've
been through
when i eat those kind of meals yeah yeah
yeah do you know what i mean yeah yeah
so when i say to you i'm intolerant i
don't want to eat it trust me when i say
to you i'm not missing i'm not missing
because it makes
me gag yeah the smell of it alone
makes me gag so i can when as soon as
you said that i empathize straight away
yeah yeah
because if you're if you have
such a strong if you hold such strong
values to such
certain things there's nothing that's
going to change your mind
you could you couldn't pay me you
probably could pay me to eat
but i wouldn't i wouldn't want to do it
i wouldn't do it willingly yeah i'd be
very reluctant yeah
the same way she's probably very lucky
to cook that steak because
it's not something she wants to do yeah
so the smell of it alone
i throwing away is extreme
i believe especially if you're grew up
in a household where you don't waste
food throwing away is very extreme
but i can understand the fact about how
she got
angry about it and wanted to like
retaliate as because she wanted to
do something about blah blah and
obviously she's trying to i don't i
don't condone her trying to change her
parents or change her family
into being vegan or whatever yeah yeah
yeah because it's her choice to be vegan
yeah
yeah
their parents are forced to be vegan i
think it's still
very harsh to for the parents to say
buy a steak and cook it because i don't
see that as punishment in my eyes
i think that's i know i feel like it's
more punishment
than it than a teach another lesson
yeah she's not learning she's not
learning anything from what from what
the parents have done yeah
they're literally just punishing her
yeah yeah yeah that in my eyes that's
crazy
spiteful that's just being spiteful that
so she's not learned anything from that
yeah yeah yeah yeah
so i feel like i still go about what i
said and still think the parents are
ourselves
because she's made a conscious effort to
change her habits and change her diets
which is absolutely fine again i don't
stand with the point of her trying to
force or not force while trying to
change her
parents and brothers views on animals
and blah blah trying to get them to be
vegans and stuff which is she shouldn't
do but everyone's trying to do what they
want whatever
but i can kind of see the gray area
do you know what i mean so i don't think
it's an easy one to deal with and it's
harder because they're family it's not
like they're
it's a friend or whatever this is their
family so she has to see them every day
she has to be with them every day she's
got no other
real choice she lives with them it's not
like she can move out
yeah so those are those are serious
factors to weigh in in my opinion
and i can always the reason why i
emphasize straight away is because as
soon as you said she smelled it i
immediately thought of crustaceans on
mollusks she's coming from in that
context but i would never throw the food
away
yeah i understand where she's coming
from so yeah i've had situations so
my when i was a kid my stepdad used to
drink a lot of red bull right
yeah and he would obviously this isn't
as extreme as your monster and stuff
like that
but my man would open a can of red bull
drink a bit of it and put the open can
back in the fridge
so when you close the fridge you open it
the next day
and everything's stunk of red bull yeah
everything
like i'd open the milk and all i can
smell is red bull i'm like how does this
even make sense yeah
everything stunk a [ __ ] red ball yeah
and i was just like what the [ __ ] like
everything smells off
um so i can kind of understand where
she's coming from
but it's more about yeah for me the mo
yeah i'll make my point now before i get
lost
in a tangent the mom's a [ __ ] and the
dada [ __ ] for making her buy me
and cook it because it's [ __ ] up
that's very good that's [ __ ] up that's
nice
it's just you're just being spiteful
yeah there's not teaching her [ __ ]
yeah um how is that teaching that yeah
and what planet does that teach her not
to waste food
to go and buy something that she's
morally against and make her cook it and
smell it
and do like why the [ __ ] would you make
her do that um
so yeah anyway that's [ __ ] up she is
an [ __ ] she shouldn't have done that
the daughter again you need to learn
to how to explain it
you need to learn to tolerate people so
if you're in a house full of meat eaters
and you ain't buying the [ __ ] food
you need to learn how to tolerate people
and it's not your mom's fault
that she made everyone chilly and that
one particular meal because clearly she
didn't have an issue
with the meat being cooked in the house
to that degree before
so yes your mom cooked a chili she made
one for you she made one for everyone
and the beef chili whatever she's made
is stinking out the fridge
and now you're saying that all the vegan
food is tainted and she has to throw
away all your vegan food and go
buy you more more vegan food think about
buy your own vegan food yeah
like buy your own like i'm not throwing
[ __ ] away like i'm not
buying you [ __ ] because it's gonna be in
packets in it like it's not actually
gonna be ruined like
understandable the smell is a bit off
and stuff like that but
she needs to understand that's in her
head yeah if you're if you've got a
[ __ ] packet of carrots
and the packet in your head smells like
the beef that your mom's been cooking
there's still nothing wrong with the
carrots yeah just [ __ ] cook them or
do whatever like
you need to understand you need to
tolerate people that there's not your
mom's fault
that you think everything stinks of me
so why
should your mom have to then go and buy
more [ __ ] for you yeah like go buy it
yourself and if you ain't got no money
it looks like you're living on rice this
weekend do i mean yeah looks like you're
eating rice this week yeah
yeah i ain't throwing [ __ ] away yeah so
yeah she whatever every area is a gray
area in that
the door's a dicker because tolerate
people don't start throwing [ __ ] away
and making demands
because of your eating habits but on the
same time the mum
is lost her [ __ ] head and she's just
doing torturous spiteful [ __ ] yeah
she knew that i was going to torture her
yeah that's so why do that she doesn't
teach her [ __ ]
um but yeah i guess the mom is to ask
the question yes
mom you are an [ __ ] definitely an
[ __ ] cool you man see you next
week